[Music]
we don't wanna rush things here but how
serious are things getting between Chris
Pratt and Katherine Schwarzenegger well
we have exclusive reporting on our
favorite new romance you could call it
quote casually dating with our et source
adding that Chris and Catherine have
been on a few dates but it's still in
the early stages Chris wants to move
slow he's in no rush for a relationship
their first sighting together was during
a picnic on Father's Day
our source says the two were actually
introduced by Catherine's mom Maria
Shriver and the two hit it off and
Catherine recently told us just how much
her mom inspires her life how do I
encourage you I don't know I feel like
to just like do what we love and to find
our passion meanwhile ETS see Chris
flying on cloud nine with Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom holding the number one
box office spot for two weeks in a row
closing in on a billion dollars
worldwide I don't know how to be present
if I can't share it with my histogram
followers this weekend the star shared
his Hollywood surprise with a van full
of unsuspecting tourists Chris Pratt
here have you seen these celebrities yet
go see Jurassic world but above all else
Chris says he's focused on his
five-year-old son Jack with X on affairs
when we can spend time together with one
another just me and him that's that's
probably when I'm the happiest and when
he looks up to me the most with
everything Chris has going on our source
says quote when he does get some free
time he spends it with cat
[Music]